[Music]
let's go to sarah in san diego
california what's up sarah
hi dr john how are you just rocking onto
the brick of dawn what about you yeah
doing well thank you so much for having
me on the course is it beautiful in san
diego
yes very sunny and warm
so great
it's cold and gray here in nashville
still beautiful but man or i think of
san diego i just think of everybody
smiling
yes it's hard to be sad there
hey so what's up
well um i have a question so my husband
and i have been married for 13 years we
have two
amazing boys they're both they're 9 and
12 years old and um
we do yes most of the time
we've made it through a tough season but
you know yeah
whenever anyone says we've been married
13 years
and we've got two kids and our kids are
amazing
that gap is usually like kind of sucks
right now kind of sucks but it's cool
like that
well it's easier than three and four i
would say years old
all right so
y'all kind of like each other what's up
yeah uh so we're both former athletes
that's actually how we met and so our
sons are very involved in sports um
we've had them in sports you know a very
young age
my husband's a a dad coach i guess if
you want to put him in that caliber and
um
over i guess the last couple years
things have gotten i would say pretty
intense with um with like his
involvement in coaching and things like
that and
um the closer that our oldest in
particular gets to high school um i just
feel like his the the intensity there my
husband's coaching and and it there
sometimes it just gets i think a little
bit over the top
um
and i i kind of want to know how to
navigate that because you know i i don't
want to get quote you know in the way i
guess of my husband and his coaching and
his intensity but
sometimes it's really i think just just
over the boundary um and just kind of an
example yeah give me an example yeah
yeah we were just a couple weeks ago
this is i guess probably why it prompted
my my question but
uh we were driving home from not a game
a basketball game but a basketball
practice and
um my husband was very disappointed with
the with the efforts given with you know
the outcome of the practice what not
and for
not even joking 50-minute car ride home
he yelled and screamed at like the top
of his lungs of just his you know
disgust his disappointment
and
in that moment i just was kind of like
you know wow this is really happening i
have to say something i didn't say
something in the car why not why not why
not why not why not
um why didn't you stop and say
nobody talks to my son like this stop
like what kept you from that
my husband's hard to approach um no no
no no i i i'm talking about like if a
rabbit dog comes chasing after your son
you like
i know mama gets in between them
i don't care about like at that point
your husband's out of control he's a
lunatic yeah he's a child
what kept mama from getting between a
lunatic and her baby
are you unsafe
no
i don't i don't think i am do you ever
get that sort of treatment
i know
sarah we've never we've never yelled and
screamed at each other but no he um
yeah and and i i think that's probably
why maybe i was very kicking back in
that moment like this what is going on
here because it's not a regular thing
well one i'm not always in the car with
them after practicing there you go it
does happen yep um but i was very like
taken aback by it and
have you talked since about it
yeah so
then that night he as soon as we got
home um he just he hit the showers like
he was just you could tell something was
going on he was you know he didn't talk
to anybody he just went the house
i talked to the kids you know let them
know hey are you okay kind of checked in
with them and they were like that was
rough i don't know why and so okay let's
you know get to bed and dinner and all
those things
and i approached him he was you know in
our room kind of tv mode just you could
tell he was chilling out and the first
thing i asked him was are you okay
and he's like yeah cool i'm good okay
and i said you know
well what just happened in a car was
i you know i'm not okay with what just
happened can we talk about it because
wow and he got really defensive and
um basically was like no i don't want to
talk about it tonight because nothing
good will come of it
and
basically the next 24 hours was just
silent that's that's kind of how he gets
when he's frustrated so i knew you know
um so the next night i approached him
again same thing kind of nighttime
boiling down it's calm he's been a
better mood
and
and he acted like nothing had happened
he was just annoyed that i was even
asking him and bringing it up and
and i basically was like hey those are
my kids they're your kids but they're my
kids too and
i you know that was that was totally
over the line and i said i understand
that you
have you're very passionate about you
know their efforts and you want to see
them do well i said i want to see them
do well too but that was just
i think more damaging and more
counterproductive and good and and i had
shared with him what the kids had shared
with me that night when we got home and
that they basically were like that's not
motivating my old disease that he
doesn't even necessarily want to play
basketball anymore
and he just kind of like wrote it off
like oh they're kids and they're gonna
do that even if you ask them to do
chores they're just you know sensitive
so here's the thing
like if that's my kid the season's over
today
they're out out
and i'm a college athlete too
i trained with a professional mma team i
know about working really hard and i
know about coaches getting in my face i
know about coaches pushing me pushing me
and pushing me this is abuse
and you're going to create a you're
going to not create you're going to
further a generation of young
people
whose
relationship with their parents is
weaponized one from the one that's
that's hurting them and the other from
the parent that won't protect them
and
that sort of rage
that he's got pulsing through his veins
ends real bad at some point
you gotta stop
and the oh they're just kids that's not
true man
it's abusive
it's absolutely stone abusive
and here's the thing you know that right
yeah
like i can hear it in you that you know
it why do you feel powerless to say not
my kids
because if if an employee at mcdonald's
talked to your kids that way you'd walk
out of that restaurant
if a teacher talked to your kids that
way they would never go back to that
school
all right and so what makes it if
another coach talked to your kids that
way you'd be off that team so fast
and so my question like there's
something there's a safety issue here
i don't know what it is
either you've lived in this for so long
or it gets like yeah i cr like i trust
you it may be so shell-shocked
like it may be so what is happening to
the man i love
but your kids desperately need to get
get them away from this lunatic
he's got something going on in him that
is deep and full of rage
yeah
over a basketball practice why would you
yell at your kid over a basketball
practice
right right it's just
if you just say it out loud it's insane
and it's not about they need to learn
how to work hard yeah they need to learn
how to work hard in responsibility and
the best way a child can learn
responsibility is not by screaming at
them and turning them into
a
just setting off every fight-or-flight
alarm they have
uh dr nadine burke-harris she's just as
she's a savant she's brilliant
she researches childhood trauma and
here's an analogy she gives
she says our our fight-or-flight systems
are designed for when a bear shows up in
front of our cave
and then our bodies signal to take off
either we fight that bear we run from
that bear
we don't have biological systems for
what happens when that bear just decides
to live in that cave
or if every day we walk into our home
which should be our safe place
there's a bear there and that's what
your kids have
and so their bodies are eating
themselves from the inside out
and i think yours is too and my guess is
his is too
if you had to guess what's going on
inside of him you've known him for a
long time what is it
um
he
i believe he's trying to live out his
dream through our kids for 100 percent
yeah and that but that intensity
his desire to live out a dream means
he's not
loving his life right now
why not
what about his current life is no good
uh that's a great question a question
i've been
wanting to know for a while
um
i i think you know
he well he's not happy where he is i
guess in life like he's with you with
his career with his two kids like what
i think i think with career in
particular i mean he's had a lot of um
uh he's an entrepreneur and he's had
just a lot of i think failures and
things in the last few years yeah and
you have to get in line on that one man
there's millions of us right yeah yeah
right and you know i i think it's a
plethora he's
yeah it's it's hard to even just
pinpoint um because it's it's hard to
really talk to him it's hard to get you
know he doesn't like to share his
feelings
um it's just yeah he
it's it's it's a lot um
and so we're doing something i don't
like to do which is to talk about
somebody when they're not on the show
um then on the phone but here's why i'm
doing that
because you're
you've set sail
and here's where this goes
you either have to turn off
your maternal instinct to protect your
kids and let dad do what dad's gonna do
you set sail into another harbor to
protect yourself
and dads and boys do what dads and boys
do and again i'm not
please hear me say
i'm not for
letting kids sit around and play video
games and i'm not for letting
like weakness that's what i'm talking
about i'm talking about abuse
and
all right let me just i'll say like
i think you know this but your marriage
is in trouble am i right
yeah it's it's been quite serious yeah
there's been stuff for the last few
years for sure yes does he have somebody
else
uh he did okay
do you
no
no
have y'all come back from that
uh
i think
not completely
you know we were in counseling for like
a year
what went sideways with that
i just
i think he's
i don't know it's it's hard to say but
he has intensity with things when he's
in the moment when there's
it needs to be intense and then it just
kind of things fade
what kind of athlete was he
like what sports or what yes yes yes he
played yeah he played basketball okay
so here's where i really struggle with
that analogy with um
like
athletes especially those who any
athlete any of them
but especially those who play sports
like with balls like football or
basketball
is you get really intense in those
moments
and everything lasers down
to repetition
and practice
and precision
and so when i hear athletes especially
former athletes especially former
athlete dads who can't let it go and are
trying to
abuse their children
through their own wacko filter
i don't buy the argument because when
those folks lasered down
they were able to follow the play and
get a layup
they were able to slide their feet in
the just the right way
to stand to
prevent the penetration from the top of
the key and to cause them to kick that
ball out and at the same time they're
already pivoting their body because that
that five is coming across the middle
right he knows all those things
and so either he chooses to be out of
control madness with his family
or he chooses to be in control
and he proved it for year after year
after year on the court and he's chosen
to not put that same level of effort and
care and love into his family that's why
that's unacceptable so i don't buy it
and your family deserves that level of
intensity and care
and energy and practice
not running a pseudo boot camp for
future former athletes
who are going to grow up and man maybe
he'll go to college great
now i gotta talk to you guys
stay way far from y'all
if your marriage even makes it that long
and here and i know i'm being hard
normally i'm not hard like this on the
show
i get real defensive of children
and i know you do too and so i'm
speaking with you here but i get real
defensive of children
and
i don't know the ins and outs of your
marriage but it sounds like there is a
nuclear reactor between the two of you
and it is slowly starting to leak out
all over the people that you all care
about and love
tell me i'm wrong or
what do you think
yeah that's
i mean you're not wrong he sounds like a
caged animal like somebody who feels
trapped
yeah i mean you feel caged too but
so what's your way forward
uh we wanted to be together i mean i i
wanted to be where
there's
you know balance um
with
with our family unit with the boys
activities with us
um
and it's it's almost like it's it's
getting kind of
in our counseling and stuff that we
talked about you know rules and things
like that and how what i could bring and
what he brings and
you know two very different people like
i like you know outdoor adventures and i
like you know going to the lake and
hiking and stuff like that and and um
you know pulling that into the family so
we can all experience that and it's
almost like that part of of you know
what we had when they were younger is
just being like suffocated because of
the sports and the day in and day out
and it's like
you know
it's it's just getting to the point
where it's really difficult to even
propose to do something like that
because there literally is no time right
and so so i want you to
in in desperate fashion quickly
you all have to create a world where
sports is not the center of your
universe
and you and your husband got some great
things from athletics i did too
really great things
and i got a lot of baggage from it too
it's both hands it's good and bad
and what i had to do and i have to do
because i've got a young son who's a
stud
he's got um physical attributes that i
never had
and when i say stud i mean like freaking
nature good
and i have had to
learn to laugh at practice
do you know what i do sometimes i take a
book to practice
not to not plug in but so that i make
sure i stay unplugged
because i have to remember he's just
playing with his buddies and he's 11.
there's no scholarships getting handed
out today
and i'd much rather him learn what
accountability is for a team so here's
my rules are you going to play
not you have to and if you don't then
we're going to have some we're going to
do some exercises and movement here at
the house
my wife picks him up and they go for
runs now because we're in between
seasons and i didn't make him i wanted
him to do wrestling so bad i wanted him
to do it so bad because i know he'd be
good for him and he didn't want to
and so he i didn't make him
but we're still doing stuff but we're
doing it as a family and my wife's like
you she likes to be outside so they go
running after school together and it's
they have a blast together and they're
they are he's gonna have to do stuff so
i'm not just saying to do nothing
if he commits to a team there's no
quitting for that season because he
committed to a team even though it's
uncomfortable even when he has to miss
sleepovers even so we're all about
accountability
and he gets to learn if you don't if you
stay up all night eat garbage and don't
practice fart then you probably lose
that's what happens
and that's where the accountability
comes in not from me screaming like a
lunatic in the car
and i can talk to him and say hey tell
me about that game where do you think
that loss came from and he can he'll be
able to articulate it well i didn't
really
put the time in on the front end awesome
how can i serve you how can i help
you know moving forward well be cool we
just play catch great you know what i
mean so there's ways to get at the
accountability without
brute force and childhood screaming
but at the end of the day
here's where we're at
you've got some real hard conversations
to have
and
if i'm you
i would you've got a lot do i protect my
boys do i protect myself do i save my
marriage i got a husband who's
struggling you got a lot going on
so if i'm you i'm making a call to a
counselor today for me
because you got to pull these things
apart and get some action plans
action plan number one is
whether it's a letter or it's a direct
conversation with husband you will not
yell at my boys like that again i need
that to be loud and clear and if this
happens again
i'm going to withdraw them from the
basketball team they will not play
and if any part of that conversation
imagining that conversation makes you
feel unsafe like you're going to get
hurt you're going to get kicked out you
got to deal with that asap
and it needs to be very clear you will
not yell at my boys
that's not motivating that's not helpful
it's none of those things i'm making
them tough it's none of those things
nonsense
nonsense they're not in the military
military hold different pro bold
different ballgame
and then you got to get serious about do
you want to save your marriage
because your trajectory in your marriage
is not good
his behavior is that of a caged animal
and it ends poorly
poorly poorly poorly poorly poorly and
if he wants to call a show i'd love to
talk to him too
but your boys need you
because they're gonna remember back and
remember dad was out of control with
rage and mom just sat there and watched
it and sarah i know you love those boys
i know that's scary and i want you to
resolve that never happens again
never happens again
got a long road ahead of you and we're
here with you sister call me anytime i
can help i know these are hard hard